if you tend to spend a lot of money
during the holidays silver state schools
credit union the sponsor of this next
segment has some tips and programs to
help you save
scott we're back on zoom how you doing
good rocky how are you i'm doing well i
see you have your logo behind you
prioritizing people over profit it's all
about community and credit with silver
state schools credit union so let's talk
about what you guys are up to with abc
loans
we'd be glad to yes so silver state
schools credit unions abc auto loan
offers an opportunity to save two
percent off your current auto loan rate
in addition to the interest rate savings
you can also wait 90 days to make your
first payment so that's great
opportunity to allow you to reduce not
only your monthly auto loan payment but
also to save that extra cash you need
during the holiday season that is great
and speaking of the holiday season how
do we get holiday cash back with the
silver state schools credit union credit
card
i'm glad you asked rocky because uh
silver state schools credit union has an
amazing cash rewards credit card
program that rewards you every time that
you use your credit card not just
sometimes but every time so this holiday
season members can earn 1.5 cash back
for every purchase every time
you can shop with
confidence this holiday season with the
silver state schools credit union cash
back rewards credit card especially at
the time where people need it the most
right and we're celebrating your 70th
anniversary so let's talk about that and
how the celebration has been going
that's right all year long we've been
celebrating our 70th anniversary and so
we're winding down our 70th anniversary
celebration and we want everyone to know
that we'll be guiding our members on
their successful financial journey and
that we've been doing that for decades
for over 70 years silver state schools
credit union has been our members
financial partner and a faithful
supporter of the las vegas community
almost anyone can become a member and
part of the silver state schools credit
union family and for more information i
want to invite you to visit
silverstatecu
there we go thank you so much scott for
the update
thank you rocky i appreciate it all
right we will talk soon
okay take care
again we want to thank silver state
schools credit union for sponsoring this
segment you can give them a call at
702-733-8820 or like you just heard
visit their website at silverstatecu.com
don't forget their special offer for an
abc auto loan to help you save this
holiday season